bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce 78
lactu qui fait le tour d'horizon de
votre information locale et nous
débutons avec l'image du jour et cette
évacuation par les CRS d'un camp de Rome
tôt ce matin à Montini le Bretonneux la
dizaine de barraquements de fortune
situé le long de la 12 dans le sens
Paris- provovince tout près du Vélodrome
accueillit 12 adultes et 9 enfants
depuis 6 mois environ il vivait le long
de la voie rapide dans des condition
insalubr et dangereuses cette évacuation
fait suite à une décision de justice les
familles vont être hébergées pour
quelques jours voire quelques semaines
pour certaines un hébergement temporaire
en échange d'un effort d'intégration
comme nous l'expliquait ce matin
Jean-Marc galant directeur de cabinet du
préfet à Versailles il leur a été
demandé en revanche pour
c'est la contrepartie ou de s'engager
dans un dans un parcours
d'intégration qui comprend la
scolarisation des enfants qui comprend
par eux aussi l'alphabétisation
l'apprentissage du français et une
inscription à Pôle Emploi c'estàdire si
s'engage dans ce dans ce dans ce
processus nous pourrons aller jusqu'à
des les inscrire dans un parcours aussi
de
logement un nouveau local a été inauguré
le 24 janvier dernier pour l'antenne du
Secours populaire à Manille et hamoau
avec nous pour en parler Daniel Reay
bénévole à l'antenne de Mani les hamoau
du Secours populaire français bonjour
Daniel bonjour euh alors avant de parler
du du nouveau local Daniel on rappelle
que votre antenne est ouverte depuis 20
ans déjà je voulais savoir quelle aide
apportez-vous au quotidien avec ce
secours populaire Daniel alors en en
grande partie une aide alimentaire nous
faisons une collecte chaque mois et une
distribution chaque mois euh des colis
d'urgence qui nous sont signalé par les
services sociaux éventuellement et une
aide aussi vestimentaire et produits
d'hygiène qui cela concerne-t-il quel
public vous recevez vous à l'antenne de
manilamo une une grande partie de alors
on a à peu près 45 familles qui
représentent 130 personnes et de plus en
plus de familles monoparentales ou des
personnes seules qui se présentent à
nous et qui ont vraiment besoin d'aide
de plus en plus alors justement im
qu'avec la crise le type de public le
type de public pardon évolue est-ce
qu'il y a un besoin plus grand est-ce
que vous l'avez senti justement avec la
crise qui s'est ancré un besoin plus
grand et comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure surtout au niveau des familles
des petites familles avant nous avions
des familles nombreuses il y en a de
moins en moins et de plus en plus de
personnes seules ou avec enfants et de
plus en plus de monde aussi oui oui oui
oui vous sentez une vraie différence
c'està-dire voilà et bien en fait on
nous adresse par les services sociaux
nous adresse des fam amille qui viennent
nous voir directement avec lesquels on
constitue les dossiers d'accueil et
quelquefois des colis d'urgence si
besoin le public c'est ce sont des
familles de manilé amau uniquement ou
oui en très très grosse partie oui oui
oui oui il y a quelques familles de
communes avoisinante qui ne peuvent pas
avoir d'aide alimentaire là où elles
habitent donc on les accueille sans
problème mais la très très très grosse
majorité c'est de manilamooui est-ce que
les demandes aussi ont évolué vous me
parlez d'un nouveau public avec des
familles monoparentales est-ce qu'il y a
des demandes différentes aussi
aujourd'hui non pas de demande
différentes particulièr parce que les
familles savent qu'on apporte plus une
aide alimentaire donc on vient nous voir
en grande partie pour cela on parle du
nouveau local on parle du nouveau local
nouveau bâtiment qui je crois vous
sieiez un peu plus l'ancien c'est un peu
compliqué de travailler avec avec
l'ancien alors on a vu quelques images
je crois qu'on va en voir peut-être de
nouvelles comment il est ce ce nouveau
local Daniel alors déjà on est content
d'avoir avoir quitté l'ancien la
municipalité a mis à notre disposition
un nouveau local tout neuf dans des des
préfabriqués tout neuf euh à notre
demande on a participé à l'élaboration
des plans et cetera c'est formidable et
on a suffisamment de place pour avoir
des pièces euh pour l'alimentaire des
pièces pour les vêtements pour l'hygiène
et cetera donc on s'est bien installé on
a été aidé par des associations de
jeunes de manie qui nous ont aidé à
déménager donc tout s'est déroulé par
parfaitement c'est ça c'est ce que ne
permettait pas l'ancien c'est de stocker
tout ce dont vous avez besoin voilà et
c'était vraiment des locaux très
vétustes qui méritait d'être démoli et
qui vont l'être d'ailleurs donc
aujourd'hui on est on est beaucoup mieux
dans ce aujourd'hui on est beaucoup
mieux c'est parfait tout va bien euh
alors tout va bien tout ne va pas bien
pour tout le monde vous continuez vous à
agir justement pour les personnes qui en
ont besoin quelles sont les les les
actions qui sont prévu pour les les mois
à venir Daniel alors toujours l'aide
alimentaire chaque mois euh des sorties
en partenariat avec le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin des sorties culturelles
qu'on propose aux familles des sorties
aussi sur Paris qu'on propose par
l'intermédiaire de la Fédération des
Yvelines du Secours populaire français
je crois aussi des programmes vacances
pour les enfants des programmes vacances
pour les enfants ou dans des familles
d'accueil ou des la JOV la journée des
oubli des vacances qui a lieu chaque
année au mois d'août où on emmène des
milliers d'enfants en vacances au bord
de la mer et voilà et bien sûr l'aide
mensuelle alimentaire voilà donc ça
comment ça se passe juste pour un petit
rappel voilà alors on fait une collecte
par mois dans deux magasins du coin
et le le weekend qui suit on procède à
une distribution envers toutes les
familles qui sont inscrites à l'antenne
et que l'on retrouve avec plaisir chaque
mois et avec qui ont nous des liens qui
sont très très affectueux et qui nous
plaisent et j'en profite pour les saluer
et remercier tous les bénévoles de
l'antenne avec qui nous travaillons avec
plaisir Daniel pour vous venir en aide
comment peut-on faire je crois qu'il y a
un bandeau qui va s'afficher avec un
numéro de téléphone c'est le Secours
populaire des Yvelines 01 30 50 46 26
comment ça se passe pour vousevenir en
aide alors c'est ce numéro c'est la
Fédération des
Yvelines à laquelle vous pouvez vous
adresser et sur place on vous
dispatchera selon l'endroit où vous
habitez et aussi on peut aussi
s'adresser aux services sociaux de la
ville de
quand on habite à manie et on dirigera
les personnes vers des bénévoles
disponibles pour les accueillir sans
problème des bénévoles dont vous avez
sans cesse besoin voilà pour l'instant
nous sommes une équipe de 13 et nous
accueillons bien sûr tous ceux qui
voudront nous rejoindre et on rappelle
que c'est le même numéro aussi pour les
gens qui sont dans le besoin et qui ont
besoin de cette aide justement ou oui il
y a aucun problème ou oui ou oui il y a
une permanence à ce numéro là merci
beaucoup Daniel pour cet éclairage et
toutes ces explications on vous je vous
souhaite bon courage dans votre nouveau
local j'avais une dernière question à
vous poser Daniel est-ce que vous avez
des livres dont vous ne savez plus quoi
faire bien sûr toujours oui toujours
bien sûr et on peut les donner quelque
part alors oui justement si vous ne
savez plus quoi faire de vos livres vous
pouvez les déposer à l'espace culturel
gondoana à Saint-Rémi les chevreuses une
librairie solidaire vient d'ouvrir au
profit d'action humanitaire romain
grabette et Elodie moine des livres à
Bacou allant de 1 à 5 € l'ONG
bibliothèque sans frontièr a ouvert une
librairie solidaire à l'espace culturel
de Saint-Rémi les chevreuses c'est
également un point de collecte où les
gens peuvent déposer leur livres les
livres sont triés une partie des livres
sont destinés à la librairie solidaire
une autre partie est destinée au local
de BSF qui est à éponene et une autre
partie va à la récupération papier parce
qu'ils sont pas récupérables ni dans un
lieu ni dans un autre les bénéfices sont
reversés au profit de projets qui
favorisent l'accès au plus grand nombre
à l'éducation et à l'information
aujourd'hui on intervient dans une
vingtaine de pays dont la France et on
intervient auprès de partenaires à
l'étranger pour les appuyer sur des
projets autour de l'accès à la culture
qui peuvent être des bibliothèques des
centres culturels en France on
intervient auprès de public en situation
de précarité notamment on intervient
dans des centres d'accueil et
d'hébergement où on a créé des espaces
bibliothèques avec des animations de
médiation autour du livre bibliothèque
sans frontière dispose d'une base
logistique à éepone et plus de 20 points
de collecte en région parisienne des
antennes devraient ouvrir prochainement
à Lille ou à Lyon 500 bénévoles dans le
monde participent à ce
projet le weekend dernier le lyonce club
des Essards le roi organisé sa 23e
édition du semi-marathon les
participants ont parcouru chacun plus de
20 km au profit des enfants malade de
l'hôpital de buon quatre d'entre eux ont
même pris part à la course un événement
placé sous le signe de la générosité et
de la convivialité yolen Torz et elodim
moine
pour sa 23e édition du semi-marathon le
Lyon club des essard le roi a attiré
plus de 1300 inscrits l'intégralité des
fonds récoltés environ 8000 € chaque
année sera reversé à l'Hôpital des
Enfants de buon on souhaite améliorer la
qualité de vie des enfants donc par
exemple les fonds servent à acheter des
vélos pour les enfants qui ont des
maladies chroniques comme des obésités
morbides un mur
d'escalade un camion spécial pour les
poliers handicapés enfin voilà quelques
enfants malades participent à la course
grâce à ces joëettes tiré par les
participants parmi eux Christian il a
emelé Antonio avec lui et et et pas
prê on a crié hurler pendant tout le
parcours à s'amuser à scander son nom à
à faire plein de choses avoir de belles
choses et puis et puis partager voilà
c'est un grand moment de partage entre
les enfants et nous ça c'est
extraordinaire parce que ça leur
provoque un bonheur fou l'idée de
participer à un tel événement sportif et
d'être au milieu des 1200 coureurs c'est
fabuleux les enfants ont même terminer
la course à pied et ont franchit la
ligne d'arrivée avec leur
équipe tu es même tombé dans les bois
je suis tombé dans les bois et alors
comment tu as fait et ben ils sont
partis dans vers les dans les arbres
à la forêt plein de fierté les enfants
ont enfin remis les prix au
gagnants et bravo à eux si vous n'étiez
pas avec nous au début de ce JT nous
vous rappelons l'image du jour et cette
et cette évacuation par les CRS d'un
camp de Rome tôt ce matin à MONTIGNE le
Bretonneux la dizaine de barraquements
de fortune situé le long de la 12 dans
le sens Paris- provovince tout près du
Vélodrome accueillit 12 adultes et 9
enfants depuis 6 mois environ il vivait
le long de la voie rapide dans des
condition insalubre et dangereus cette
évacuation fait suite à une décision de
justice les familles vont maintenant
être hébergées pour quelques jours voire
quelques semaines pour certaines un
hébergement temporaire en échange d'un
effort d'intégration comme nous
l'expliquait ce matin Jean-Marc galant
directeur de cabinet du préfet à
Versailles il leur a été demandé en
revanche pour c'est la contrepartie ou
de s'engager dans un dans un parcours
d'intégration qui comprend la
scolarisation des enfants qui comprend
par eux aussi l'alphabétisation
l'apprentissage du français et une
inscription à Pôle Emploi c'està-dire si
s'engage dans ce dans ce dans ce
processus nous pourrons aller jusqu'à
des les inscrire dans un parcours aussi
de
logement c'est la fin de cette édition
nous on se retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition justement je vous
laisse maintenant entre les mains de
clerire Cambier pour filcho et à 20h je
vous rappelle rendez-vous pour un
nouveau débat municipal 2014 avec
Wilfried rich ce soir Bertrand Ouillon
et Aurore berger autour de la commune de
manilamo excellente soirée sur TVfil